- She's healthier than me.
(rock music)
- Ever since I can remember,
I have made a conscious effort in my life
to have a incredibly
clean and healthy diet.
I am vegan
and I tend not to eat too much gluten.
- Eating food is equal to happiness,
so I really need to focus
on eating what I like.
A lot of junk food, usually.
- My mom was really into health,
and so it's something I grew up with.
- I'm sure that when I
start eating healthy,
it'll probably, you know,
do something magical?
I mean if it doesn't,
I'm never gonna healthy, so.
I think for me it's
gonna be hard mentally.
But physically it's
gonna be harder for you.
- [Cameraman] Dun dun dun.
- [YB] So literally all my
favorite foods in there.
- Okay, pizza.
Oh you put in parentheses,
"I can usually eat the whole pizza."
"No vegetables on it, hehehehe."
(laughs)
So I guess I'm eating a whole pizza.
Let's go.
- So breakfast smoothie, I like smoothies.
Blueberries, kale, banana,
wheatgrass powder.
What's wheatgrass?
- Wheatgrass is um,
it's a grass.
- So I'm eating grass.
- Yeah.
- I think one out of 10,
I'll do maybe like eight.
- I think I'm gonna do terrible.
(laughs)
(curious music)
- So Saturday morning
I went to get the smoothie
for my breakfast smoothie.
And then I got a wheatgrass shot
because they had it.
- She's gonna have a wheatgrass shot
and then you'll be like,
"I can take on the world."
- Ugh.
It's like, not good at all.
It's like warm grass.
- I did the whole Saturday
morning cartoon thing
in bed with my Reese's Puffs.
Just really, really sugary.
I don't know if I can
eat a whole bowl of this.
But it's kind of good.
- So it's 11:50
and I finished the smoothie
while I was driving,
and I am so hungry.
I'm used to very carb heavy breakfast.
So I was getting kinda hangry.
- So I went to yoga Saturday afternoon.
I was really tired during class.
It's as if the sugar from the cereal
just rushed to my brain.
And all I wanna do is go
get a giant Green Juice
to (bleep) cleanse the
sugar out of my system.
- Sky is drinking something healthy.
Whatcha drinkin'?
(sad trombone sound)
- I cheated, okay?
But after dinner I made up for it.
I ate a whole bunch of Doritos.
I'm gonna eat so many of these.
These are (bleep) amazing.
Wow.
- Smoothie time.
Oh, it's good.
Oh, I thought it was gonna
taste like really bad,
but it's really good.
I even went hiking with my dog,
and I was like feeling good.
I was like, "Yeah, I feel
healthy and I have energy!"
The only sucky part was
like after I came back home,
I was super hungry and, you know,
and tired.
But I had to cook again.
- I really failed.
I failed hard.
I'm just gonna admit it.
I should've been better.
I should've stuck to the experiment more.
But I felt the effects.
And,
Sunday night dinner,
I went through the Burger King drive-thru.
- You are the last person I would imagine
to even accept this challenge
because of how often we discuss health
and how often I see you doing, like,
pushups in our backyard.
(laughs)
- Hi, can I have a small fries and a Coke?
Like I feel, if anyone saw me doing this,
it would just ruin my image.
French fries and ketchup,
I can dig that.
But I don't know, like,
I don't have a burning desire
to eat the rest of this.
I'm not craving this.
I'm craving a Green Juice.
- So,
we eat the kelp noodles with pesto, salad,
some kale.
I want other stuff.
I want, like, chicken wings.
And I want burgers, pizza,
other stuff to go with it.
I would prefer it with
just like normal noodles.
I think that would be really, really good.
But this is a healthy alternative.
(upbeat music)
I'm really glad I did this challenge.
It was a really,
like I learned a lot.
I learned how to cook a little bit.
And I learned about a
lot of other ingredients
that I didn't know about.
- Like, I've realized
throughout this experience
that the food that I eat
is so much a part of my identity.
And not having it,
I feel like I'm not myself.
Sweet Chili Doritos are the bomb.
That's all I'm gonna say about that.